Доброго дня шановні друзі мене звати
Ірина Шумик і я генеральний директор
директорату професійної освіти
Міністерства освіти і науки і Сьогодні
ми з радістю хочемо презентувати до
пілотування перші 6 онлайн-курсів
короткотермінових онлайн-курсів які були
розроблені спільно з нашими партнерами
чому взагалі виникла така дітей створити
подібні курси це власне відповідь на ті
виклики які сьогодні диктує нам війна
багато хто Втратив роботу багато кому
потрібно підвищувати кваліфікацію або
змінювати свою професію і
відповідаючи на ці виклики допомагаючи
нашим громадянам ми спільно з програмою
Європейського Союзу і юфорс Kills краще
навички для сучасної України а також з
нашими фінськими партнерами розробили 20
онлайн курсів Ці курси є
короткотермінованими вони передбачають
набуття певних навичок і часткових
компетентностей Сьогодні ми починаємо
пілотування перших шести з ним з них
вони пов'язані із соціальною сферою з
охороною здоров'я з будівництвом Та
інформаційними це технологіями Це ті
сектори де навички сучасні навички
знання сьогодні є необхідними всім і
кожному дані курси стануть у нагоді Під
час вивчення відповідних профільних
предметів як студентам і здобувачам
професійної освіти так і будь-якій
дорослій людині це дозволить вам оновити
свої знання і з користю використовувати
їх на практиці Запрошуємо до пілотування
вітаємо вас із АС по у Фінляндії Мене
звати мерві Янсон і я виконавчим
директором
моя технічний партнер Edge тобто
національна агенції освіти Фінляндії у
концерті
і ми співпрацюємо із
міністерством освіти і науки України для
того щоб підтримати розвиток
професійно-технічної освіти в Україні
сьогодні я з надзвичайної приємністю
Оголошую запуск першої групи наших
онлайн-курсів для самостійного вивчення
які спрямовані на те щоб підтримати
відбудову України Вони
спеціально підготовлені для керівників
закладів профте освіти здобувачів освіти
викладачів та всіх хто цікавиться
професійним розвитком і розвитком своїх
навичок
теми курсів були підібрані разом із
командою пані Ірини шубіка і ми дуже
вдячні експертам українських закладів
професійно-технічної освіти які
переконалися що всі курси добре
підходили до потреб української
громадськості Ми сподіваємося що вам
буде цікаво проходити цей курси і будемо
дуже цінувати
будь-які ваші відгуки після завершення
цього курсу Ну тепер не буду більше вас
затримати послухати більш інформації про
Ці курси дякую
краще навички для сучасної України це
спільна програма ЄС та його країні в
членів Німеччини Фінляндії Польщі та
Естонії для підтримки реформи
професійно-технічної освіти в Україні
мета програми і у фоскілс підтримує
реформу
професійно-технічної освіти в Україні з
метою зробити навчання таким що
відповідає вимогам ринку праці та
допомогти молоді та дорослим реалізувати
власне потенціал
в рамках програми і ufos Skills ми а
саме національна агенція освіти
Фінляндії у консорціумі зовні Education
put нашіпс IP Фінляндія розробили 20
короткострокових курсів в онлайн-форматі
для підтримки відбудови України наразі
ми презентуємо розпочинаємо процес
пілотування перших шести курсів
мета курсів метою курсів є забезпечення
підтримки у навчанні конкретним
професійним компетентностям в різних
сферах усіх бажаючих здобуваючи освіти
викладачів а також дорослих зокрема осіб
працездатного віку які бажають пройти
перепідготовку або підвищити свою
кваліфікацію курси передбачають
опанування навичок затребуваних на ринку
праці й актуальних для відбудови України
в разі необхідності курси можуть бути
включені до освітніх програм з
конкретних професій спеціальностей у
цьому відео Ви отримаєте загальну
інформацію щодо курсів Також ми
продемонструємо вам як зареєструватися
на курсі та легко орієнтуватися у
матеріалах курсу а також яким чином
залишити свій відгук після проходження
курсу
наразі Ми презентуємо перші шість
короткострокових курсів що охоплюють
сферу соціальної роботи та охорони
здоров'я будівництва та інформаційних
технологій кінцевий термін проходження
перших шести курсів 28 лютого 2023 року
наступні два етапи заплановано на січень
та лютий 2023 року розглянемо ці шість
курсів більш детально та дізнаємось які
переваги одержать учасники від їх
проходження
послуга щодо забезпечення роботи
інформаційних мереж ознайомлення з
матеріалами курсу допоможе вам зрозуміти
як працюють інформаційні мережі які
послуги вони пропонують принципи
мережевого трафіку та способи усунення
помилок ви навчитеся використовувати
базові протоколи та служби усувати
несправності виявлені у мережевому
трафіку
система фізичного захисту інформаційних
ресурсів ознайомлення з матеріалами
курсу допоможе вам правильно визначити
пріоритети побудови системи захисту
інформації та збереження ваших активів
ви зможете навчитися як розпізнавати
можливі ризики та загрози враховувати їх
під час реалізації проекту безпеки А
також правильно документувати
використання та обслуговування систем
фізичного захисту інформаційних ресурсів
курс буде особливо актуальним для
керівників закладів освіти
зокрема директорів а також власників чи
користувачів навчальних виробничих або
комерційних приміщень також він може
бути корисним ширшому колу учасників
робота на будівельному майданчику мета
цього короткострокового курсу навчити
здобувачів освіти основам безпечної
роботи на будівельному майданчику та як
правильно використовувати робочий
інструменти під час будівництва оскільки
після закінчення війни в Україні
проходитиме активна фаза відбудови
надзвичайна важливо підготувати
кваліфікованих Будівельників Цей курс
сприятиме цій меті
сприяння підвищення добробуту та
соціального захисту родини
упорядковане повсякденне життя сприяє
добробуту всієї родини поради надані в
цьому короткостроковому курсі допоможуть
вам сформувати рекомендації родинам які
потребують налагодження добробуту
робота з дітьми в кризових ситуаціях
короткостроковий курс роботи з дітьми
кризових ситуаціях допоможе учасником
курсу зрозуміти як криза впливає на
життя здоров'я та добробут дитини
підлітка та родини а також дізнатися про
сучасні методи які можуть
використовуватись працівниками сфери
охорони здоров'я або соціальних послуг
для надання підтримки дитині та її
родини під час кризи зокрема в умовах
військового стану
перша домедична допомога перша домедичну
допомогу включає знання та навички які
ви можете опонувати та використовувати
на практиці кожному Варто знати для чого
надається перша домедична допомога та
яким чином її слід надавати також дуже
важливо відпрацювати ці навички для
використання на практиці в реальному
житті що під час надзвичайної ситуації
ви змогли спокійно дотримуватися
алгоритму дій та використовувати
необхідні засоби та прийоми при наданні
першої домедичної допомоги
Зараз ми покажемо як орієнтуватися в
короткостроковому курсі це стартова
базова сторінка на якій можна обрати
конкретний курс який вас цікавить
коли ви натиснете зробите клік на певний
курс ви перейдете на відповідну сторінку
курсу
перед початком курсу учасником необхідно
зареєструватися реєстраційну форму можна
знайти на головній сторінці курсу
курс складається з кількох розділів які
ви можете побачити на панелі меню зліва
це перший розділ
розділи містять тексти
відеоматеріали з українськими субтитрами
та безпосередньо українською мовою
шаблони в PDF форматі та інтерактивні
цифрові інструменти
метіметр patled та Singing
в кінці розділу є кнопка переміщення яка
дозволяє учасникам перейти до наступного
розділу
в кінці курсу а саме на останній
сторінці необхідно пройти онлайн
оцінювання
учасником необхідно ввести свої
контактні дані до відповідної форми
після завершення тесту ви побачите свій
результат відсоток правильних відповідей
для одержання сертифіката необхідно
набрати мінімум 70% від загальної
кількості правильних відповідей
у цьому випадку ви одержите сертифікат
який можна завантажити на сторінці
результатів тесту також сертифікат буде
автоматично надіслано на електронну
адресу яку ви вказали у формі анкеті на
початку тесту
Після пілотування курсу залиште будь
ласка свій відгук
в рамках проекту і уфо Skills ми
запускаємо програму тренінгу керівників
закладів професійної
професійно-технічної освіти в онлайн
форматі Сучасні підходи до управління
закладом професійної
професійно-технічної освіти в умовах
інтеграції в європейській освітній
простір
орієнтовано на керівників закладів
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
а також дорослих населення осіб
працездатного віку які бажають пройти
перепідготовку або підвищити свою
кваліфікацію
ключовою метою програми є опонування
сучасних підходів до управління закладом
професійної
професійно-технічної освіти в умовах
інтеграції в європейській освітній
простір програма складається з модулів
які відповідають основним напрямом
підвищення кваліфікації визначеним
європейським фондом освіти модулі були
розроблені У рамках цілісної логічної
структури всі вони є пов'язаними між
собою кожен модуль слід розглядати як
складову частину програми а не як
окремий самостійний матеріал
програма складається з 10 модулів
екологізація професійної освіти
інформаційна система управління закладом
освіти
управління змінами управління сучасним
педагогічним процесом у професійній
професійно-технічній освіті
управління людськими ресурсами навчання
підприємств в закладах професійної
професійно-технічної освіти лідерство та
розвиток лідерських навичок управління
якістю професійній професійно-технічній
освіті
співпраця між підприємствами та
закладами освіти
професійно-технічна освіта на основі
компетентнісного підходу
Зараз ми презентуємо першу частину що
складається з шести модулів екологізація
професійної освіти
інформаційна система управління закладом
освіти управління змінами управління
сучасним педагогічним процесом у
професійній професійно-технічній освіті
управління людськими ресурсами навчання
підприємству в закладах професійної
професійно-технічної освіти
у цьому відео ви дізнаєтесь Більш
детальну інформацію про цю програму а
також як орієнтуватися в матеріалах
модуля і зареєструватися щоб розпочати
навчання
Запрошуємо всіх бажаючих до реєстрації
Зараз ми покажемо як орієнтуватися в
модулі це стартова базова сторінка на
якій можна обрати конкретний модуль який
вас цікавить коли ви натиснете зробите
клік на певний модуль ви перейдете на
відповідну сторінку модуля
перед початком навчання необхідно
зареєструватися
реєстраційну форму можна знайти на
головній сторінці
перейдемо безпосередньо до модулю
модуль складається з кількох розділів
які ви можете побачити на панелі меню
зліва
це перший розділ розділи містять
текстові
відеоматеріали з українськими субтитрами
або безпосередньо українською мовою
шаблони в форматі PDF та інтерактивні
цифрові інструменти
в кінці розділу є кнопка переміщення яка
дозволяє учасникам перейти до наступного
розділу
в кінці а саме на останній сторінці
необхідно пройти онлайн оцінювання
учасником необхідно ввести свої
контактні дані
після завершення тесту ви побачите свій
результат відсоток правильних відповідей
для одержання сертифіката необхідно
набрати мінімум 70% від загальної
кількості правильних відповідей у цьому
випадку ви одержите сертифікат який
можна завантажити на сторінці
результатів тесту також сертифікат буде
автоматично надіслана на вашу електронну
адресу яку ви вказали в анкеті
по завершенню модулю ви можете залишити
свій відгук
посилання на відгук знаходиться на
головній сторінці